Wow last week I asked you welcome
everyone to the why my favorite show yay
fan voted top show of 2018 it's been my
pleasure this year Wow can't wait to see
what more red it means he's gonna go
through this time leave your entries in
the ready Crows
[Music]
Oh
let's get into the memes Wow what means
do we got what happened this week three
ninety-nine percent accurate
why can't I find a guy like this hey no
he is literally the guy in the pink
Thank You Vox very cool this is what
gets top Boden really sixty cups can we
go back to family-friendly alright
that's it that's it I'm pulling the plug
Christian now that's right I'm Christian
we're back to Christian Channel this has
gone too far I had enough Christian
channel god dammit I mean gosh darn it
hey look at that my own video almost
makes it my own content which wasn't
even made by me but still thank you guys
so much for all the support on this
video it was really fun for everyone
involved I think don't forget to sub to
although my second channels let's remind
Felix that this picture of him exists
likes 9 that was a weird 2016 was a
weird time I'm not gonna lie yeah I
don't want to remember that one thank
you thank you though thank you so much I
have such great fans so when did you hop
on this wild ride
during the Bros the Golden Age Scott
Pham the Dark Age 9 year olds the
Renaissance man sir get it right you
dumbasses Vox News needs to get on this
damn that's sexy
how old is a DVD screensaver FBI oh god
damn it the great the great subscriber
war did you do your part it ain't over
till it's over god damn it I made a
vicar pedia infobox for the war against
T series commander soon leaders the best
part zero deaths don't challenge me
things might change very soon be careful
what you wish for
let's confuse new fans of PewDiePie I
don't get it
what if this is supposed to mean what
does that golden statue and why does he
look at a lien sheesh that's weird
didn't know that's right I am Christian
Channel what oh my god hello
what happened I'm scared
Christian Channel Chris Oh Christian
Channel that's right everybody I have
converted feel free to bless my videos
with as many ads as you please thank you
very much
DVD logo hit a corner the entire
universe that's a great move petition to
give Felix two to four days off to
decorate his office Wow look at that
guy's
he put a TV on the wall I think I
deserve a whole week off okay I think
I've done my part to say the least you
know I work hard what can I say make the
DVD screensaver played in the background
yeah all right yeah it's not like I got
60,000 comic are you happy now is this
what you wanted do you feel contented
because if you do smash thumbs up on
this video if the DVD corner hit the
corner what the hell am I saying Jesus
Christ have I been making videos for ten
years hit the corner smash light do
whatever you want
guess what I got for Christmas a fake
ass pretty pie chair what the [ __ ] is
that
am I supposed to be happy where's the
Italian leather where's the unique PD PI
design huh don't talk to me only one
chair can properly do this don't make me
laugh huh Aluna Larionov a slob Queen
covered with lasagna and it sounds
really good we should get Felix to
listen to it
actual weather there should have been
sook and lasagna but very good to say
the least
III really appreciate all the covers
it's so fun to see let's remind him if
this gets ten thousand retweets I will
tell what I stole at least fake ass
tweets I didn't tweet this you ain't
fooling no one
you can't fool the fool there you can't
fool the fool your channel name a more
iconic dual I'll wait
I'm not supposed to give my opinion but
any news media basically and bible
review bible who is this guy you see
what is my doppelganger doing stop it
let's pray everyone part one out of 500
this is making me uncomfortable like
that's too far a lot of times people
send me doppelgangers are like oh if I'm
like yeah I guess this is just genuinely
scaring me what the hell this thing who
is that man I know it's me I know that's
me I don't like that what if I can make
him make my videos and I don't have to
make videos anymore
find me more that man god I mean gosh
darn it we need this man Papa needs a
break your move Media perfectly
acceptable automatic injection of
seventy eight million nine year olds
into the Nazi Party the funny thing
about that constant which is use as
constant evidence for me like oh how
could you do this
that's a British soldier outfit
literally you can buy it off Amazon I
know I said this before but it's just
one of those things that people keep
posting there you go
British Home Guard soldier costume Oh
could he do this
shut the [ __ ] up you [ __ ] dump
goddamnit it's hard to be the Christian
a guy made a diamond dislike button for
YouTube and Senate we know you will do
better next time also subscribe to
PewDiePie that is very epic this is made
by Bobby Duke arts this absolute man lad
may be his own diamond play button oh
that looks legit actually that looks
really good I mean you just flip it
upside down and it hits a thumbs up
button right or not I'm just saying if
YouTube crying in the corner that's
really cool if pewdiepie plays
Wolfenstein that mainstream media will
stop you can't be an Aussie if you kill
Nazis oh really
okay you know whenever I get attacked by
media they seem to conveniently forget
solid evidence that I have that protects
my name alright is no one gonna talk
about PewDiePie versus Hudler for one
hour straight okay why is the one
talking about that one time I fought him
for one hour straight okay why is no one
talking about this why does Vox media
not report about these sort of things
smh s MH crying RN okay it makes me sick
their bias it's just too transparent and
I think it's time to stop now it doesn't
even just end there okay what about that
one time right after Willis Street
Journal where I killed Hitler okay
[Music]
I really wanted to get his one testicle
you see what I'm talking about here I am
freakin H seriously though 10 million in
12 hours and Ninja is still first this
is eight hours ago I have to agree why
is the video not on trending like why
it's my most successful video but I
think I've done at least this year why
is it not on trending I think a lot of
people misunderstand trending because
they look at views and they go what that
video has more abuse than that one so it
should be trending but that's not how
they measure the metrics there's a
significant increase or maybe a lot of
outside viewers are coming to one
channel and watching one video that's
the sort of thing that measure it but
this is such a massive video that and I
had other videos trending for way less
so it's very confusing I'm genuinely
concerned that they actually decided to
not put it on trending because he makes
YouTube look bad which is just
ridiculous obviously I don't have any
evidence for that that's just mere
speculation but it's very confusing we
could have gone way harder on it we
could have been really like mean and
vicious but I think it's very
light-hearted humor about it at least in
my opinion so it's disappointing maybe
it will change by the time this video
goes up we'll see I bet I can guess your
age take oh it's gonna be 9 isn't it
yeah yeah oh god yes
ok so everyone's been sending me this
but I haven't reacted to it properly
[Music]
Jablonski huh you challenged me don't
make me laugh what is 48 it's a
fortnight I also appreciate the fact
that he has very clean songs usually
when I wear white socks might they get
very dirty very quickly what's the
difference between bread and bread
beautify pays for bread crime war Brad
stop trying to sneak your memes in
Tooele why Jesus Christ this is all
Felix hand-me-downs this was Felix isn't
it yeah it is he's very that is mine so
all of his stuff is high-quality so I
just go and steal it and he's so rich he
doesn't realize that it's missing it's
really funny I just go into his house
and I'm like oh hey bro and he's like
hey I'm just recording a video I'll be
with you in a minute and I'm like ok
I'll have that I'll take that and I just
[ __ ] off he sends me a text like well
where did you go are busy busy he goes
it's quite the craziest thing that's
happened my speakers have gone missing
I'm like oh man if only you could
if only you could pay for more with all
of that money that you don't pay me or
save with I'm never gonna pay you again
am i I just realized the sad truth this
onion won't make me cry PewDiePie will
eventually stop making videos when he
gets old this onion won't make me cry
everyone is gonna die meme review
everybody subscribe
happy 5 years on this date 5 years ago
Peter PI secured his spot for the number
one most subscribed youtuber in the
world this street was incredibly close
to ending multiple times over the past
couple months but we made it thanks to
this dedicated community I'm so proud of
this community so December 23rd damn I
remember hearing about this when it
looked like t-series was just about to
pass and I thought it would be so cool
if we could actually make it so that we
hit the five-year mark I never thought
we would I never thought we would
actually last this long so that's really
cool I'm really proud to have been in
this spot for so long
really means a lot to me I am genuinely
so proud of this community yeah you
laugh you lose mane skip that wait what
is that reason or an old one all the
wrestling fans mother I love the perfect
framing of this that's so good
that's some pretty old-looking nine year
olds in the back as well yeah took me
three hours but worth it 2011 2012 2013
2014 2015 2016 2017 2018 I guess I
haven't changed my style that much
that's pretty cool then I wish I could
just pick a style and go with it but
just constant self-loathing moan
allowance what should I wish for
I wish per fortnight and marques
Brownlee what happened he used to be
such a legend Peter pie reveals plans to
move to Japan we'd soon to be Italian
wife in recent video you know who else
knockout dammit yeah okay stop stop it
guys please Christian Channel can we all
just go back to when life was simple god
damn it it's so true it's kind of sad if
you think about it just in terms of edgy
content you know filthy Frank was such a
pioneer in that genre
now the bubble has sort of burst in a
sense that that type of content would
just never fly any more on YouTube
demonetized videos just get censor then
it's a kind of humor in a style of
comedy that we'll probably never see
again oh my god what is happening you
know even for me doing the slightly edgy
joke I'm all this like it was a joke it
was not even pressure forget the video
monetized but then getting publicly
slandered and and all these things
combined with it it's kind of sad it
makes me almost wish that there was
another website although I can't
complain YouTube is going great for me
so I'm pretty happy
can't be too whiny about these things
you know it's Christmas after all all
things put aside like YouTube has
improved massively for that for me at
least the past six months I don't get
problem with the monetization most of my
issues come with copyright claims or RBS
and stuff like that so I'm very happy
I'm also very proud of you guys I'm very
proud of what we've done here with Lawai
in this community and it's been a great
years honestly one of my favorite years
on YouTube so thank you guys so much for
this year of love I hope you guys
enjoyed smash like by the merch where
the merch throw away the March buy more
March and then as always goodbye
oh god end the video click away click
away is it gonna do it
[Music]
you